it was a dangerous night for police  officers in two separate states one  officer was killed and another seriously  injured in Kissimmee Florida near  Orlando late Friday the officers were  checking people in an area of the city  known for drug activity when they were  shot they were unable to fire back three  suspects were arrested a fourth is being  sought is it getting tough it's it's  getting tough to do the job that we've  all sworn to protect and uphold and and  and maintain livable neighborhoods keep  people safe and and you know these  senseless acts are going on a few hours  later in Jacksonville two police  officers were shot and wounded both  officers are expected to survive the  suspect was killed and two Pennsylvania  State Troopers are recovering after they  were shot it happened at a convenience  store about an hour south of Pittsburgh  police say the suspect was killed at the  scene